Hey
our series coming home follows our
nation's servicemembers as they return
from deployment the USS Harry s Truman
an aircraft carrier carries more than
5,000 sailors they just returned from a
groundbreaking military mission it was
the first carrier deployed as part of
the Trump administration the so-called
dynamic force employment strategy it
involves warship sailing in
unpredictable patterns to confuse
potential enemies the Truman was the
first carrier in decades to monitor
Russia from the Arctic Circle because of
that unpredictability families back home
were kept in the dark for much of the
deployment CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson boarded the Truman
days before its return in a story you'll
see only on CBS this morning she
followed the sailors as they reunited
with family members Dana good morning
good morning a lot of people have not
been on an aircraft carrier so for those
who have not the best way to describe it
a small floating City for the ship we
went on the Truman that meant a city of
over 5,000 sailors with all of their
loved ones waiting for them back home
[Music]
[Applause]
it is a once-in-a-lifetime view as the
massive Navy carrier the USS Harry s
Truman pulls into port the thousands of
sailors streaming off the boat haven't
seen their families in months
their history-making mission was a
strategic success but it was at times
unsettling for the sailors and their
family we flew out to meet the sailors
for their final days onboard from the
flight deck the size of four football
fields to the cramped hallways no one
really knows like what it's like to be
on a ship these young men and women in
uniform were reflecting on their journey
what's the hardest thing about being at
sea and being away from family probably
say missing my thirst for culinary
specialist Devin Dyess the mission his
first has been one of both excitement
and sacrifice i'ma get you Devin's wife
Taylor Dyess went into labor in October
I called my wife I like maybe all right
is everything good she's like well you
know I'm just having a baby I was
actually very very fortunate to be on
the phone with her during the birth so
every screen
Grau push I got to hear it will really
change my perspective was I heard him
whenever he first came out with every
cry it actually brought tears to my eyes
maybe paralegal faith Guidry Jackson
also on her first deployment is worrying
about her children too I've kind of been
out of the loop for three months has it
been harder on anyone of
my youngest Marley she's she's four
she has like these night terrors you
know it's you know she's like calling
out for me but I'm not there Faith's
husband LaVon has been a solo parent to
their three kids while working in a
barber shop in Norfolk it's been crazy
isn't that whole I think missed a mom
more than anything but they miss their
feminine energy that she brings into the
house the 24/7 nature of the ship keeps
the sailors busy leaving less time to
think about those they've left behind
and the Navy provides some comforts of
home got a good haircut awful bit about
myself today from a barbershop to a
library even a Starbucks
but there are some things they can't
provide Cryptologic technician mike
guess key and his fiancee connie Cole's
a key got engaged over the phone while
they were apart
Connie's love with my life I don't know
what her I would be without her but he
never officially popped the question
with ring in hand we were pulling into
Portugal earlier than we expected
and my parents somehow found a flight
out to Portugal and I told them as long
as you're coming here you might as well
bring the ring with you excited to meet
your dad while anxious families at home
wait for the last few days of deployment
to pass on the ship there's still work
to be done like getting the carrier's
Air Wing off we are one of the last
flames are gone now that
are gone
[Applause]
the family reunions and the overwhelming
emotions that come with them begin here
[Applause]
back on board
I gave nervous anxious excited really
nervous the final days turn two hours
then two minutes as the sailors line up
for the traditional Manning of the rails
and Naval Station Norfolk comes into
view home is finally within their grasp
on the peel anticipation is building
after months apart those final minutes
are agonizing for everyone especially
for a new dad like Devin Dyess about to
meet his son but for the first time
thank you
how's it feel
[Music]
want to give me a kiss
Livan Jackson doesn't even try to
contain his excitement
[Music]
now I'll get the kid face children
didn't know that mom was coming home her
deployment now over I miss you hey hey
back on the pier sailors step back on
land ready to swap Navy life or home
life and for one young couple a chance
to start affairs
[Music]
[Applause]
the little details rights the
technicality the ring Connie and Mike by
the way actually set to get married on
New Year's Eve it breaks me every day as
I stood with them it's just so amazing
to see the reunions of these families
seven months out there at sea of course
is a better answer I think then yes and
I always love I love you I love you more
oh I have a kiss - yeah I mean there
were so many you know someone reminded
me this morning who's dealt a lot with
deployment that there's this moment of
reunion which we are all so grateful for
that they're home safe but then there's
the readjustment when they are home and
it is important remember too that
families fall into a routine when when a
member is that's exactly it Norma knew
comes back into the routine so we have
to keep them in our thoughts and prayers
for the months that follow because that
reunification is difficult and they were
all aware I talked with all of them
about how difficult it would be stepping
into this life that their loved ones had
had without them exactly what you're
saying they do try to work with them a
little bit on the ship about some of the
things Devon took a new parenting class
learned how to die for that kind of
thing but it is an adjustment yeah all
the more stunning when you know that
they they choose to serve right they are
not exactly exactly ultimate sacrifice
day yeah that was Bob thank you right
I've been on the heart what a beautiful
store thank you